I can't quite believe it but I'm here at
the London Film and Comic Con and I'm
sitting here with Darth Vader himself hi
Dave they go very nice to be here thank
you very much now I know that you
actually fell into showbiz and it was
through a role you had in a film called
a little film called a Clockwork Orange
that you actually got the role as Darth
Vader didn't you tell us about that
sorry well I just I did this some
standing Kubrick ramya one day I said he
was doing this film Clockwork Orange and
asked me if I would go to this house and
nothing was in Radley I've been up in
North London and we film this we film
this terrible movie Hercule it was quite
strange actually because I mean I mean
the first scene I did I was doing
nothing else but carrying Alex who was
Malcolm McDowell down the stairs I did
all day like you know non-stop and and
at the end of the day I can hardly move
like I'll move our arms like you know
and then Stanley turns around me said oh
he said to the next day so we're gonna
do this thing where you can they carry
Patrick Magee down the stairs in his
wheelchair I said hang on a minute I
said I said I said short things that
won't take Kubrick is really you know I
said all we do as quick as we can you
know and we and we shot the scene at
about three or four takes he was a hard
taskmaster to work or buy a lovely guy I
loved it my god gone very very well with
him and then of course no that came out
in 1971 I think it was and luckily for
me George Lucas saw it because it was
out very very briefly yeah because it
was a it created a lot of bad publicity
and
the content of the film and anyway I
said Lucas thought in the very brief
period that it was out and I remember me
for five years and then came and came to
London and set himself up in the
twentieth century-fox offices in London
central London and got in touch with the
managing director and said look do me a
favor can you can you find me this bad
day pranks No
and then like I called in I said I said
well how did you know me and he's always
at for your quick orange so if you
couldn't have four Stanley Kubrick
you're good enough for me you know and
that was it that was a no-go became
Darth they said you can either be
Chewbacca or you can be the big villain
Darth Vader and you chose to go to the
dark side didn't you what was he feel
well they were showing me that well they
showed me all these conceptual drawings
around the room and to Becca was like
this or a harry's like gorillas like you
know and and it was we we actually
filmed all the way through 1971 that the
hottest summer we've ever had in Great
Britain like that and all I could think
of when I saw the cube a cat costume hot
and sweaty that's gonna be like you know
the recouped input I've been that for a
couple of months like you know and and
so I many-to-many turn around said with
you you can either pay true back or you
can play the big villain of the film
well thank you very much I know I know
which part like never have like you know
go for I'll go for Darth Vader thank you
and and he said well he said nobody will
ever forget our theater and here we are
30 odd years later yeah exactly yeah
yeah
mind you Chewbacca I mean still is a
very very popular character wore white
they're all these big conventions you
know we meet up all over the world
because he now lives because he's a
stranger because he knew he was living
in Croydon and I live in Croydon as well
and so the stranger the two two guys
from Croydon should become a major part
of this huge you know phenomena and
and now of course he what he did he
eventually left he left he left Croydon
and went to America to live and got
myself married and he lived very very
happily happily man I think he's raising
pigs or something like this over and
over in Dallas yeah different than being
two back isn't it
maybe more do you think when you saw the
costume after you sort yourself right
I've dodged a bullet there getting rid
of that fur I think I think I saw the
Darth Vader you know I saw that all the
conceptual drawings and what Darth Vader
was gonna look like I meant of course
you know I had to go to the theatrical
costume me and things like this and I
was basically very impressed the biggest
problem for me was a helmet in the mask
and you know keep it keeping the helmet
on in one place and every because
everything was made miles too big and it
was a question is that they said well no
it looks it looks absolutely perfect
here proportionately to your body and
the sign the character itself you know
so they're not only won't alter it's
been quite warm in there we film we film
during the hottest summer we've ever had
in Great Britain I was making 76 and I
mean it was it was it really was baking
like you know but you you you you
learned very quickly how to UM how to
live with the costume as it were and as
much that used to I used to go into the
studio's first thing in the morning and
just put the trousers and a t-shirt on
and that's all sand used to stay like
that as long as you possibly could and
then they used to clip any to say well
we want to do it rehearse and so you
then used to put a few of the other bits
and pieces on like you know how many you
used to rehearse and then they said well
now we want to film the rehearsal so
then you have to put everything on there
and
and but the main thing was used you've
stayed out of the helmet the mask and
the capes as long as you possibly could
that yeah yeah like fighting people like
Alec Guinness and what kind of a little
dress like that more fun than yeah than
anything very very serious I mean with
with Sir Alec we had we've had centre
Rangers and I mean weeks before the film
started I was going to have I was going
to rehearsals with with a stuntman and
rehearsing the fight and Malick Guinness
was doing the exactly the same thing
with a stunt arranger where he lived
because he lived in like then and
Hampshire somewhere like her and then
when we when we actually started work on
the movie then you know we I would say
to him if you want to come next door it
is one of the studios is quiet we can go
and practice so the two of us she was
going like kids fighting around with
these sticks rolls very dear to you as
well which is very different to this
which is the Green Cross code man so
it's been very best job I've ever had
loved every minute of it at 14 years I
went to I thought well I said I went to
I went to schools I used to do three
schools a day five days a week for the
entire school periods for 14 years I
didn't know I didn't know other work
then I didn't I didn't didn't do any
film or television work all that true
and all that here at apart from that
from the school holiday periods when you
know when I could when I could obviously
to other work but to me it was like
warmers became the vocation and I loved
every minute came to me tomorrow I said
how would you like to go Green Cross
code in all over again I jump at it yeah
I love
I loved it oh it's been absolutely
lovely to speak to you Dave enjoy the
rest of the weekend
thank you very much lovely thought
you